clevenger says what do you think about
the experiment at skinwalker ranch
that's another subject i'm extremely
interested in at skinwalker ranch and
the new info on portals i don't know
what that new information i don't know
what they're referring to i don't know
okay matthew if you can at me so that i
can see it
explain what you mean by the new info on
portals either way he wants to know what
you think about the experiments going on
at skinwalker ranch oh hell skin walker
so you have uh billionaire robert
bigelow back in the early 1990s forms an
organization called the national
institute for discovery science nids
he brings help hud off on we mentioned
but off
uh dr kit green formerly of the cia very
interesting man i know kit
john alexander
eric davis
brilliant physicist colm kelleher
another brilliant scientist
and they one of the things they settle
on is
this place called the sherman ranch in
utah
and uh it had a long history of alleged
paranormal activity and they
they called skinwalker ranch because i
think it was the ute uh tribe
uh
talked about these beings called
skinwalkers these
and um
and it was associated with this property
so what you have with skinwalker is
a long
multi-year
and in fact it's
been revisited skinwalkers you know the
tv show unidentified the ttsa creation
basically
they returned to skinwalker
but back in the 90s when uh
they were
going full guns on this with their
instrumentation
[Music]
they were tracking a lot of very bizarre
phenomenon there
not just ufo sightings there were cases
of ufos there but there were cases of
uh portals
or apparent portals or alleged portals
there were cases of
uh
crypt kryptoid type creatures that
weren't supposed to exist like the dire
wolf like this massive well
apparently it
the owner of the ranch took several
shots at this thing and all he did was
piss it off and it just grumpily turned
around and walked away after he he
loaded it with i think he had a shotgun
um
there is
you know jerry jeremy corbell who you
interviewed did a documentary on
skinwalker ranch it's called skinwalker
the best part about that documentary in
my view is the old footage that the
journalist george knapp acquired back in
the 1990s on some of it's fascinating
there's a cattle mutilation case at
skimwalker in the 90s that is absolutely
just baffling
makes no sense
how that could have happened the way
that it did so you've got a case where
it's believed
and there were other things they had
like classic almost poltergeist activity
going on at the house according to
george knapp and colm keller who wrote
the book on this the hunt for the
skinwalker
so there's a lot of strange things going
on there
people say it's a portal you know where
where the i don't know how do you the
the layer between our world and the
other world is thin and
is it can that be true yeah i don't know
i'm not i'm not the physicist who can
say yes or no this is true but
something very strange about that
property without a doubt
is there any relationship between ufos
and bigfoot
some people might say yes um i don't i
don't know what that i would say yes or
no on that there are a few researchers
if you talk to bigfoot researchers and
i've talked to a few of them
they're interesting people there you got
a fellow named lauren coleman out in
portland maine
coleman's quite experienced very
knowledgeable man yeah it would help me
actually if you went through some of the
people you consider to be most credible
in the bigfoot field later we'll talk
well i just named lauren and i think he
is lorien lauren coleman
without a doubt
he runs a he runs a i think it's a
bigfoot or like a cryptid museum
in portland it's a cool place
very cool place
uh
there's another
another older researcher named stan
gordon of western pennsylvania who
equally has done ufos and sasquatch or
bigfoot sightings in western
pennsylvania in fact stan wrote a book
called
on the year nine on one year on the year
1973 in which he compiled
uh ufo and bigfoot
sightings in western pennsylvania
because he was following them up and he
put them together and it was stan's
contention that they are related
there's another researcher who i think
might not
agree with that and that's dr jeffrey
meldrum who teaches
where the hell is he teaching idaho
jeffrey meldrum's his phd
they they try to get him out they try to
like run him out of his university but
they can't because he's got tenure and
uh
he's done a lot of very detailed big uh
he doesn't use the board bigfoot he
calls it sasquatch but he does
tremendous amount of research on that so
within that community you've got a split
you've got the people there who believe
that all these cryptids
these cryptozoological creatures are
simply natural earthquakes like the
coelacanth when that was discovered in
the 1930s everyone thought it had been
extinct for millions of years and then
they find it holy crap we got one of
these things you know from the age of
the dinosaurs or whatever here it is so
there are people who believe that
bigfoot
or the yeti you know
that maybe it's just a
an evolved species on our planet that
right is very secretive so that's one
school of thought
and i don't want to speak for jeffrey
meldrum here because i could be wrong
but
my impression is he he might be leaning
toward that school
definitely stan gordon
does not
and i don't know what lauren coleman
thinks you'll have to ask him but anyway
then there are people who do argue that
there's a definite paranormal
element to sasquatch or bigfoot
whether they connected to ufos
i don't know i don't know how they they
think of it do they think he's the
interdimensional entity i mean you
definitely hear this a lot what does it
even mean to be an interdimensional
entity who the hell knows i try to
understand what's another dimension how
is it possible that there's a membrane
here and just right like six inches from
my nose is another universe i i hear
this
i don't know how to understand that idea
frankly my common sense just recoils but
you've got all these theories about
interdimensionality
okay so maybe that's true
but
you know
what do i think i don't i don't know
what i think i've talked to bigfoot
witnesses
they're every bit as compelling as a ufo
witness there's no difference
none in my opinion so i mean i you you
talked to these guys
one of them said to me he was out in
oregon in the forest he's like i was 60
feet away from this thing he's a hunter
he was like in his mid-30s sharp guy
like seemed very honest i was hunting
i see this bigfoot
and i said the natural question well how
do you know it wasn't a bear he said
because we don't have brown bears here
we have black bears this was brown so
secondly
i know what bears are this a bear he's
just like well i don't know what to tell
you i'm 60 feet away that's less than
that's the distance from the pitcher's
mound to home plate
you can get a pretty good view of
something at that distance
and uh
he said it looked at me it stood
straight up i was scared out of my mind
i started backing away slowly he said
and it just turned around and walked
away walked away that's his story
am i going to call him a liar i don't i
don't call him a liar i've talked to
several other
bigfoot witnesses they they seem to be
as on point as ufo witnesses so who am i
to tell them that they're lying
i don't know what to make of it i don't
know what to make of it
this next
you